- It’s time for the Week 14 playoff picture.
- It’s time for the—Damn you, Adam Schefter.
- Nice try, Rapoport.
- Uh, should we be doing this in front of an active volcano?
- Everything is totally normal. But please, Steelers, come over here.
- Here?
- Actually, hurry, move again.
- OH, LOOK! KETCHUP.
- [Together:] Patrick, no!
- Cheese.
- Wait, who is in the NFC East spot?
- HI, I’M KURT UNCLES AND I PLAY FOR THE DELAWARE CLAMS.
- OK, let’s move Gruden out.
- Oh, per Adam Schefter, Gruden’s out.
- I risked catching lava for this, man?
- Any room for—OH GOD, OUR HOUSE.
- DO YOU SMELL WHAT THE LAVA IS COOKING?
It's us.
- Yo, man. They can stay with me.
Whoa, there’s a volcano here?! That's wack.
- The NFL has added precautions for safety.
- ALL DONE!
- I’m very disappointed in you, Drew Lock.
- All right, Colts should somehow be in the photo.
Bring in their most exciting player.
- Hi, I’m Rodrigo Blankenship. This is just like the Star Wars planet Mustafar!
- [Together:] What?
- Gesundheit!
- According to reports, Lamar’s taken a step back.
- I have not taken a step—AHHHH.
- OK, I am now hearing the volcano is in fact out of control.
- BUT! Let me add: Run for your lives.
- [Together:] AHHHHHHHH!
- We make the playoffs and the world f--king ends.
- MAKE SURE YOU TAG ME IN THIS.
- [Schefter] Tua, over here, Tua. I'm the No. 1 guy. Tua.
- [Rapoport] Tua, hey, right here. Hey. Hi. Hey.
- [Schefter] This way, Tua. Look at me. Tua.
- [Rapoport] Right here, look at me, Tua. Tua, over here. No, Tua.
- [Schefter] TUA. This way, to me.
- [Rapoport] Tua, no over here, Tua. Tua. Look at me, Tua. Tua.